okay so what's the misogynistic opinion
well the other day I saw a video and he
was like you know men when they cheat
they're not like they love somebody and
like they come back to that person that
they love but if they cheat and then
they come back to that person like
they're only cheating because let's
consider that an exercise like it's just
an exercise you're just going to the gym
for a couple minutes and then you're
gonna and I was just kind of like damn
like what a way to put like cheating on
your wife is that misogynistical like
because misogynistic means like you hate
women like an inherent hate for women oh
I mean maybe that's not the right word
then gotcha